des milliers de soudanais ont de nouveau
défié les autorités en prenant la rue
dans la capitale les forces de sécurité
ont repoussé la foule à coups de gaz
lacrymogènes alors qu'elle s'approchait
du palais présidentiel
au moins deux manifestants ont été tués
lors des marches qui se sont déroulées
dans plusieurs villes du pays
depuis le coup d'état perpétré à la fin
octobre une cinquantaine de personnes
sont mortes lors de ces manifestations
qui se succèdent pour réclamer le retour
d'un pouvoir civil
la tête du soudan
nous manifestons pour la chute du
pouvoir militaire dit elle
il faut en finir avec les militaires au
pouvoir en shérif se manifestant
la fragile transition démocratique qui
s'était amorcée en 2010 9 après la chute
du dictateur omar el-béchir a
brusquement pris fin le 25 octobre
dernier
l'armée a décrété l'état d'urgence et
limogé le gouvernement d'abord arrêter
le premier ministre qui était en poste a
été rétabli dans ses fonctions devant
les pressions internationales
à l'issue d'une entente avec les
militaires incapable de former un
gouvernement de transition
il a finalement annoncé sa démission
aujourd'hui dans un discours télévisé il
nous aura j'ai fait de mon mieux pour
empêcher le pays de glisser vers la
catastrophe dit il il souhaite
maintenant passer le flambeau à
quelqu'un d'autre pour le moment le
pouvoir reste donc concentré entre les
mains de l'armée du général abdelfattah
al murr anne
l'incertitude vient encore d'augmenter
d'un cran ici olivier bachand radio
canada montréal